يعود اليك نايف من الدوحه يسعد هالصباح
مجددا نايف بعد شهر من الاحتفالات شهر من
الاقتضاض السكاني وكل السياح عبر العالم
حضروا الى قطر لحضور المباريات اليوم شو
راح يصير هل بلشتوا تحسوا من منذ هذا
الصباح انه الامور عادت الى طبيعتها ما
قبل شهر من اليوم
يعني سته اهداف الامور كثيره وقد تكون بدا
يومنا اليوم بمغادره البطل يعني قبل قبل
ساعه غاده وتحافله المنتخب الارجنتيني همم
مقر سكنها باتجاه المطار حمد الدولي
ستنتقل بطائره خاصه الى بيقول هناك
تنتظرها الجماهير وبالتالي همم ستاد
الجماهير اتباعا يعني همم هناك ازدحام
كبير وهمم عدم وجود مقاعد اللي على
الرحلات المغادره من مطار الدوحه اليوم
وهمم غدا ايضا ولكن بعيني يعني همم همم
على ذكر السعوديه والمنتخب السعودي دائما
وكان هناك سؤال يتردد للجماهير
الارجنتينيه ويرز ميسي بالامس لما كنت اجي
لقاءات مع الجماهير الارجنتينيه همم احد
المشجعين وبالتاكيد هو وارجنتيني ويعلم
اني سعودي اول ما همم بدات المقابله معه
همم سالني هو ويلز ميسي ولم يمهلني ان ارد
عليه وضع اصبعه على قلبه وقال هنا وجلب
لنا النجمه الثالثه ايضا كان هناك
احتفالات من بعض الفرنسيه همم الفرنسيه
رغم الخساره انهم قالوا انه نحن سعيدين ان
همم انها ذهبت ل همم ميسي من ضمن التجاوب
الجميله التي رصدناها خلال طوال الشهر وهي
التي لن تتكافل نهائيا في اي كاس عالم اخر
هي قدره على التنقل بين اكثر من مباراه
وهذه خذناها نحن اعلاميين وايضا كجماهير
تستطيع عظم المترو ان تحضروا المباراه ولو
تحضروا المباراه الثانيه وتحضرون مباراه
الثالثه بكل سهوله ايضا دعيني يتحدث عن
نقطه مهمه واعتقد انها ستغير المفاهيم لدى
المنظمين في البطولات المقبله نعلم ان قطر
منعت همم مبيعات الكحول في الملاعب هذا
الامر ساهمه كثيرا في الحد من المشاكل ومن
الاشتباكات ومن احداث الشغل وايضا من
الاصابات بين الجماهير بالامس نتواجدت في
مسيرات الجماهير نحو او نحو منطقه
البوليفار كانت الامور تسير بثلاثه كان
العناصر التنظيم عددهم قليل بكثير بسبب
هذا الامر ايضا امس الاحتفالات التي كانت
في البوليفارد هذه لاول مره في تاريخ كاس
العالم ان تقوم الدوله المستضيفه همم
الفريق البطل شاهد الاحتفال والمسيره صارت
بشكل مميز بسبب هذا الامر همم
اخر مره راح تلبس هاي تيشرت لانه عليها
نجمتين
الحصول على نجمه الثالثه بعد فوزها
للمره الثالثه في تاريخها بمونديال كاس
العالم فخلاص هيحطها سوفنير عندك في البيت
شكرا جزرا نايف
كان ودي ان ميسي يوقع
عليها لكن ما صوت فرصه شكرا يعطيك العافيه
شكرا جزيلا